Понад три тисячі кілометрів доріг в Україні відремонтовано.
В інформаційній брошурі Кабміну це подається
як одне з головних досягнень уряду Володимира Гройсмана
за два роки при владі.
За даними "Укравтодору", минулого року відремонтували
дві тисячі сто кілометрів доріг,
і це рекорд за останні п'ять років.
Водночас це лише трохи більше одного відсотка
усієї мережі доріг державного значення.
У перший рік правління уряду Гройсмана
було відремонтовано ще 800-900 кілометрів автошляхів.
Тож загалом дані про три тисячі кілометрів
відповідають дійсності.
Але що це за ремонт, і чи надовго його вистачить?
Це не ямковий ремонт, а так званий поточний середній
з гарантійним строком 3-5 років.
Простими словами  - це коли знімається верхній шар покриття
і кладеться свіжий п'ятисантиметровий шар асфальту.
За словами експертів, говорити про високу якість
такого ремонту не доводиться.
Особливо це стосується ремонтних робіт 2016-го року.
Навіть чиновники визнають, що переважна більшість
відремонтованих тоді доріг з дефектами.
При цьому підрядника складно притягнути до відповідальності.
Він може легко через суд довести,
що експлуатація доріг не відповідала стандартам.
Зокрема, перевантажені фури, особливо влітку,
одразу "вбивають" дороги.
Дієвий контроль за перевантаженням відсутній.
2018 року уряд планує відремонтувати
ще щонайменше три тисячі кілометрів доріг.
Утім, навіть з такими темпами знадобиться
понад півстоліття, аби відремонтувати усі українські дороги.
Обнадійливим принаймні є той факт,
що поступово з’являється конкуренція між підрядниками.
Якщо раніше цей ринок був монополізований і корумпований,
то нині в Україну починають заходити
турецькі, білоруські, китайські ремонтні компанії.
Позитивний сигнал для бізнесу –
ухвалення 5-річної  держпрограми розвитку автодоріг.
Тепер компанії можуть планувати перспективу
на 5 років, а не на один, як було раніше.
До речі, вже за два роки так званий поточний середній ремонт,
на який нині припадає найбільше витрат,
має стати історією. В "Укравтодорі" обіцяють робити акцент
вже на капітальний ремонт та нове будівництво.
Це завдання полегшить децентралізація:
з 1 січня "Укравтодор" відповідає
лише за 50 тисяч кілометрів доріг державного значення,
інші 120 тисяч передано в управління місцевої влади.
Те, що в Україні відремонтовано три тисячі кілометрів доріг
за два роки –здебільшого правда.
Однак аби оцінити значимість цього твердження,
необхідні додаткові пояснення та інформація.
ередусім щодо того, наскільки якісно
відремонтовано ці дороги і якою є їхня частка
в загальній мережі доріг.